AND GET OUR HEALTH COMMITTEE
HEARING STARTED YOU'LL SEE WE
HAVE A LACK OF A QUORUM HOWEVER
WE CAN GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
WE HAVE ONE WILL BE FOR US A.
B. FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE BY
MISTER LOWE WERE HERE TO
WITNESSES PER SIDE IN THREE
MINUTES EACH OUR STANDARD
PROCEDURE. THIS IS. EIGHT
FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE FIFTEEN
TWENTY NINE BY MISTER LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I MY APOLOGIES FOR
HAVING TO CONVENE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE JUST FOR THIS ONE
BILL BUT THE COMBINATION OF
THIS IS WITH RESPECT TO
UNIVERSAL CARTRIDGE IN MAKING
SURE THAT THE INDUSTRY IS
COMPLIANT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR.
WITH THIS IS A SUPPORT YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. AMY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. AND CAN I CRAFT
WANT TO APPLY THE AUTHOR FOR.
AT TAKING AN INTEREST IN THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY I WOULD JUST
NOTE ENSURING THAT UNIVERSAL
SYMBOL IS CLEARLY PLACED ON THE
VAPE CARTRIDGE. IS PARTICULARLY
RELEVANT NOW GIVEN SOME OF THE
RECENT INCIDENTS HAVE BEEN
REPORTED ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
CONSUMING UNSAFE VAPING
PRODUCTS SO. WE APPLIED THE
AUTHOR FOR MOVING FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE ENCOURAGE
WRITER THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE'S
SUPPORT. YEAH YEAH GOOD MORNING
MR SURE MEMBERS JASON BRIAN ON
THE AFTER THE CAMPUS
DISTRIBUTION ASSOCIATION WE
AREN'T SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. TIM LYNCH ON BEHALF OF PAX
LABS IN WORDS FOR THE BILL.
THREE EMILY HUGHES ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CAMPUS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ALICIA CREATE ON
BEHALF OF EASE IN SUPPORT. TEN
MORE THAN I'LL BE HALF A KILO
CONFECTIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
READ MORE NOW BEHALF OF
CLEVELAND FROM SUPPORT. MUCH TO
ONE IN OPPOSITION. SEE NO ONE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. MR
BIGELOW. QUESTIONS PROBABLY
MARTIN FOR THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL AND IT AND IT'S ONE OF THE
AS WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE LOGO
AS IT'S BEING. DOWNSIZED
SLIGHTLY WHICH- DOESN'T MAKE
MUCH OF AN ISSUE I THINK THE
RECOGNITION OF WHAT IT IS IN
THE ABILITY FOR THE INDUSTRY TO
MARKET THAT AND HANDLE IT MORE
EFFECTIVE WAY IS GREAT. BUT
THERE IS A LITTLE SPACE
UNDERNEATH THERE THAT'S GOING
TO BE AVAILABLE FOR
UTILIZATION. IS THERE GOING TO
BE A WAY TO MAYBE HELP CLARIFY
SO PEOPLE WILL KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE WHETHER OR NOT THAT
IS. THC OR WHETHER IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO SEE SO THAT CAN BE
MARKED ON THEIR IN A CLEAR WAY
SO THE USER WILL NOT CONFUSE
BY. BY NOT KNOWING. SOMEONE I
REALLY APPRECIATE QUESTION IT'S
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT WE INTRODUCED THE BILL
YOU'RE RIGHT THERE IS A LITTLE
BIT OF SPACE. BELOW HOWEVER
WHAT WHAT THE COMPANIES ARE
DOING TO ENSURE THAT THAT
RATIO. IS CLEARLY VISIBLE IS
THERE EITHER HAVING TO NOT
INCLUDED THERE THEY'RE JUST
THEIR BRANDS ON THE V. PART.
FOR PROVIDE THE RATIO BECAUSE
IF YOU TRY TO PUT IT BELOW IT'S
VERY VERY SMALL AND IT WILL BE
HARD TO SEE BUT TYPICALLY FOR
PATIENTS. A LOT OF WHOM USE ONE
STRAIN OR A RATIO DURING THE
DAY AND A DIFFERENT STRAIN BY
NIGHT SO. SO ALLOWING THE
VAPOR. OR THE SYMBOL TO NOT
HAVE TO WRAP AROUND THE PRODUCT
LEAVES ROOM FOR THE RATIO
DESIGNATION AS WELL AS THE
ACTUAL PRODUCT. LOGO ITSELF.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S THE CONCERN I'VE
GOT. THE CONFUSION THAT MAY MAY
COME ABOUT SO IF THE INDUSTRY
IS LOOKING AT A SOLUTIONS SO
THAT WE- CAN CLEARLY HAVE THE-
CUSTOMER KNOW THE DIFFERENCE OF
WHAT THEY'RE USUALLY. USING
WILL WITH SOME CLARITY THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL THAT'S CORRECT
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
IT'S ENOUGH FOR HAVE A QUORUM
SEVEN HAVE BEEN SECRETARY TAKE
THE ROLE SO PLEASE PLEASE DO SO
WHAT HERE MAYES AGUIAR-CURRY.
BIGELOW BONTA BURKE CARRILLO
FLORA LIMóN MCCARTY NAZARIAN
RAMOS RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO.
WALDRON OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM
SO. MR LO JACK CLOSE YEP
ADVENTURE MUCH HARDISON MOTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
WITH THAT MADAM SECOND THE
MOTION IS OF THIS IS THE
CURRENT CONCUR IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED RE REFER. TO BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS THIS CASE IS
GOING TO COME RIGHT BACK OUT
YOU. NO SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WOULD WOULD AYE MAYES AYE
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE BONTA BURKE CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA I LIVE
ALONE. MCCARTY NAZARIAN RAMOS
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
WALDRON AYE. YOUR BILL HAS NINE
VOTES IT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT
COMMITTEE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON.
THANK YOU MISTER LEFT. AND WE
WILL I LEAVE WE WILL WAIT FOR A
FEW MINUTES AND LET OTHER
MEMBERS COMING OUT ON BUT-
WE'RE NOT GONNA WAIT ALL DAY.
THAT WAS IT THAT'S ALL THE
BUSINESS SO. YEAH
. WE HAVE A
MAN SECTOR OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON A. B.
FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE.
AGUIAR-CURRY BONTA BURKE LOAN
LUAN AYE MCCARTY. NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE. SELECT SO THAT'S
ELEVEN ZERO WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER STAT ON THANK
YOU
. OPEN THE ROLE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON A. B. FIFTEEN
TWENTY NINE AGUIAR-CURRY BONTA
BURKE BURKE I. MCCARTY. WHAT
THAT STANDS TWELVE ZERO
.
MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY BONTA
BONTA ALIVE. HI A PRESIDENT ON
BOTH. MCCARTY THANK. SO THE
THAT IS THIRTEEN ZERO AT THIS
POINT WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE
ROLE AND CLOSE THE MEETING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH